one of the new stars of the upcoming
icarly reboot has become the subject of
racist attacks lacey mosley who plays
carly's new best friend harper posted on
social media showing some of the hateful
comments being made about her
in the original show carly's best friend
sam was played by jeanette mccurdy
[Music]
jeanette decided not to return in the
upcoming revival announcing she's
actually quit acting
and some of the racist comments seem to
take issue with carly's now best friend
being black
get the [ __ ] out of my comments with
this racist
bull you will be blocked and you will
never see me again
lacey posted a picture of those negative
comments writing
i've been deleting and blocking people
but i can't be bothered anymore stay mad
i felt silly being upset by racism
because it's just how this terrible
planet is
but sometimes it still catches me off
guard
thigh carly starr later tweeted that she
learned racist comments were also being
made about her on tick tock
on monday the actress opened up about
how she's coping writing
i was shocked when a celebration of all
the hard work we put into making this
reboot
was overshadowed by the most racism i've
ever experienced
over the course of 72 hours i'm not
replacing sam i've never met her
but i know she's extremely talented and
i hope she does not condone some of
y'all's behavior
racism kills she also adds that she took
the role on icarly because the room is
diverse
praising one of the show's writers
francesca ramsey
who has since spoken out on twitter she
wrote
it's both racist as hell and completely
unfair to decide that lacey hasn't
earned her role
especially since the show isn't even out
yet a statement from the show's creative
team was also shared on social media
saying they are proud to be racially
diverse not only in their crew but in
the cast
miranda cosgrove who plays carly stood
up for her co-star by posting the
statement on her instagram
and jerry traynor who plays carly's
brother spencer
captioned it i never want to hear the
phrase icarly fans are racist
ever again i need the true fans to step
up and drown out the hate
just last week the cast celebrated
miranda's 28th birthday by announcing
their official release date
hi carly premieres
[Music]
lacey took to instagram to honor the
actress on her special day writing
i've never found a new friend on a job
so quickly miranda
you're a hilarious talented beautiful
and kind individual
the beloved nickelodeon show premiered
in 2007
and ran for six seasons before it ended
in 2012.
et recently caught up with the og cast
at this year's kids choice awards
where nathan kress who plays carly's
best friend freddy
spoke about the new cast members the
three of us got back together and was
like
just riding a bike it was like we're
back
the cool part is what makes it different
too is we have new characters that are
coming as well so it is
a lot of the familiar you know it's a
lot of familiar faces but there's new
people involved that are going to change
up the story a ton and make it
very interesting uh and i think somewhat
[Music]
unexpected